[music]
Narrator:
Did you know that on campus you can rent a bike for just 15 bucks a semester?
It's thanks to a program called U-Bikes, working together with the Cyclab. They can be found in a building
Narrator:
behind the WaWa that you've seen and probably not cared about before.
Mars Jullian:
There are a lot of bikes on campus that are left here by students who pay $100 for a Walmart
bike and then realize it costs $200 to ship it home. So, Public Safety will collect all
Mars Jullian:
these bikes, and then we'll take them, and we'll add new parts on them, and we'll send
them back out as part of our rental program, so that these bikes aren't just left to waste
Mars Jullian:
on campus, so that they can be reused and re-ridden.
Narrator:
U-Bikes also rents out over 100 of these beautiful orange bikes. Plus, they'll give you a stylish
helmet and a bike lock for free!
Anthony Cross:
This is the Cyclab. It's Princeton's community bike co-op. It's a do-it-yourself space --
we have tools, we have volunteer mechanics like myself to help out, and it's basically
Anthony Cross:
just a space where the Princeton community, the university, can come in and learn how
to work on their own bikes, how to fix up their bikes, how to do basic repairs -- where
Anthony Cross:
the bike community at Princeton can come and hang out and work on bikes.
[music]
Anthony Cross:
(We're) just kind of creating a bike culture here so people can really ride their bikes around.
[music]
Anthony Cross:
I just volunteered to help out, and I've been doing it ever since.
[music]
Tessa Maurer:
Damn, I did a number on this bike.
[music]
Tessa Maurer:
So, I basically just got my bike revamped for seven whole dollars.
Narrator:
Here's a fun fact: Riding a bike instead of driving improves cardiovascular health and
reduces your emissions by 100 percent.
Narrator:
So, stop by U-Bikes, and help build a sustainable transportation model. Others will follow.
[music]